[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: We've published
APIs in the developer portal.
Now let's look at
monitoring and analytics.
Apigee Edge includes a number
of built-in analytics charts.
The most basic is the
traffic volume chart.
Here you can see traffic
volumes over time--
over the week,
the day, the hour.
You can also select
custom time periods.
All of this is powered by
Google Cloud Analytics,
so you get great performance
from these charts even
with huge API traffic volumes.
That's traffic volume,
but thinking outside-in,
we'd like to understand
the experience users are
getting from the APIs.
What's the response time?
Here we can see the median
response time as well as
the 95th percentile and
the 99th percentile.
Analyzing these
trends can help you
identify when your
backend services start
to show strain under load.
In fact, Apigee
Edge analytics can
be a major benefit
of Apigee Edge
even if you don't perform
transforms or apply security
in your proxy.
This response time
insight can be invaluable
as you perform A/B tests
or roll out new services.
Now let's look at
error reporting.
In any high-volume system,
there will be errors.
Some are good errors,
like a 401 when
an expired token is presented.
Some are unexpected.
With the error code
analysis chart,
you can examine
error code trends
and better understand where the
errors are occurring and why.
This chart can give
you that clarity.
These are just a few of the
analytics charts that are
available out-of-the-box
with Apigee Edge,
and you also have the ability to
create custom reports that show
data you care about.
Which clients are trending up?
Which device types
show the most errors?
How does traffic
volume vary over
the course of a day or a week?
How effective is the cache?
Which versions of my
API are in low use
that I might deprecate them?
Using Apigee Edge analytics gets
you visibility into your API
program that you
absolutely need in order
to understand usage and
manage your API efforts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]